if you think of memory you know memories
and all all encompassing term going from
just being able to integrate the last
few hundred milliseconds of your sensory
experience together that requires memory
right because that you know a few
hundred milliseconds a second is longer
than the direct memory of most neurons
it requires integrating everything in in
an intermediate structure which is you
know short-term memory there's many
different forms of memory and it eats I
stop there right it's a a eternal it
really is an all-encompassing word in
that we call memory very very different
things my interest the theoretical level
in in memory has to do with the lack of
theoretical models for what we call
normal in memory namely we have a fairly
good artificial neural net models for
implicit associations or form you know
implicit recognition of categories and
the like so if we show a number of
examples of a category or a number of
examples of currencies we can build
neural artificial neural networks these
are artificial computational structures
okay which we run on the computer that
look at these categorizations and
eventually learn from the presentation
of examples how to you know how to
categorize certain things so that we
know how to do but in in common language
memory is a very different thing and in
common language basically everything I
remember happened to me exactly once in
Washington you get these many different
examples and you categorize from
then you you recall very vividly
instances that happened to you like I
said precisely ones so I I remember
vividly the birth of each one of my
children I do not have just some
category called birth of children I
recall each one of them I recall my
first day of school happened to me just
once well I recalled my first day of
elementary school and I recall my first
day of high school okay and I recall
them as two different instances not as
two examples of first days of deep of
schools right so we do not have much by
way of a theoretical understanding of
how the brain could do this okay we
don't have very well developed models of
a sort of a neural network taking all of
these data from the world and assembling
them into some into some the co hidden
thing with Holden memory whereby if we
recall it we remember things that
happened on one specific occasion that
we so precisely wants right so that's
that's an interest they have but I have
to say that you know we don't have
currently a lot of a lot of results in
the subject
you